[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man it's rough this morning
it's the afternoon what are you talking
about i'm still kind of sleepy
[Laughter]
we've been running with these kids all
around town tearing the [ __ ]
up we went out last night too yeah we
wanted two nuts in a row we haven't done
that in a long time
i know and now we know why i gotta
recover
yeah it was well it was actually fun i
was like because we went out friday
night it was
fun even though i had to like rush after
we did the show
and i'd already drank a lot before we
got there but we had a good time and
then saturday we're like oh let's go
again i'm like oh dude i don't know if i
can do it and uh i had a couple drinks
at home
yeah and then i went out there and i was
like i just i'm gonna fall asleep on the
bar i just can't take it but then like
after i had a couple drinks i was like
oh yeah i woke up
yeah then they played alien sex fiend
and i'm like okay that that cheered me
up
yeah there's kind of
all right so today today is fourth of
july isn't it it is
yeah happy independence day everybody
and uh you'd think we'd probably be
doing something about barbecue or
something
we've well we thought about that that
was something to talk about that's yeah
that's the first thing i thought it
was like man that sounds kind of boring
and then you came in and said oh let's
talk about american breakfast and i said
oh that's a good idea because
uh we did a little section of that in
our uh cookbook
yeah and um breakfast is my favorite
meal of the day even though i don't
usually eat it yeah isn't that dumb
the strength of american breakfast is
the speed at which it can be cooked
there are other countries that have
breakfasts but sometimes like they're
they're kind of sometimes they're
complicated or they're so simple that we
wouldn't consider to be breakfast
like in brazil when i was living in
brazil
they have something called cafe de mayo
which means [ __ ] morning
cafe morning coffee it's not breakfast
okay it's just coffee maybe some fruit
uh like slices of melon or something
maybe some strawberries
um and then like a piece of uh i guess
it'd be like italian style bread or a
piece of french bread
yeah with some butter on it and it might
come with a little slice of cured ham
and
maybe some white cheese or some some
sliced slices of like such
brazilian cheese to be similar to say
like monster okay
which that means you you can now make a
ham and cheese sandwich
but it's still not breakfast by american
standards
brazilians just just waking up and
having a coffee and
putting something in their stomach
before the commute it's not the same
our breakfast is i think based upon an
english breakfast
yeah because the full english is kind of
similar i think well the full english
usually has i think it has tomatoes
yeah like sliced tomatoes and doesn't
also have beans yeah it's like that
one of the one of the weirdest things
that i saw people eat for breakfast over
there was canned
spaghetti on toast and i was like
that's rough i my stomach can't face
that kind of [ __ ] that that time of the
morning i just you know what i mean
the uk was kind of in a different
economic position
after the war and their the culinary
arts were kind of stunted compared to
the us they were very
heavily reliant on canned food you know
and a lot a lot of meat and beef type
stuff would have
been imported i mean they did have beef
and and but it's mostly lamb it's what
they're eating
i think they they had pork yeah but um
a lot of stuff that you know the average
person in england [ __ ] growing up in
the 50s and 60s was like here in the
united states it was cats
really but the american breakfast
i think the strength was is just how
fast you could cook it
out of a diner fried eggs hash browns
fried strips of bacon fried slab of ham
pancakes toast
sometimes fruit maybe waffles maybe
waffles with if if there's
if there's waffles then there's fruit on
the waffles you know sometimes either
maple syrup
um grits if you're in the south will be
thrown into the mix
biscuits and gravy biscuits and gravy
home fries
yeah home fries which is uh kind of like
hashbrowns kind of like hash browns it's
just cubed
yeah fried pieces it's actually
faster to boil them boil a bunch of
cubed potatoes drain the water out
and then fry them in a pan season them
put
green peppers and onions red peppers in
there with it you know
and you season them to taste you can use
them as components and other things
one guy i was watching he was making
corned beef for breakfast and he used
leftover french fries yeah which is
actually a pretty good idea
now there's also an element of like
fast food and eating on the go with a
lot of american breakfast
um when we when when i was in the army
our chow hall had [ __ ] great
breakfast and they could feed it
thousands of dudes very quickly
and uh it was a mixture of stuff like
they'd make an omelet to order and
or eggs to order and throw that to you
and you walk through the line and then
the rest of it was kind of like a buffet
style and you learned real
quick you know we were inventing our own
foods
okay as soldiers franken foods they were
like franken foods
because you didn't want to spend all
morning in the damn chow hall
okay you did you you wanted to go back
to the barracks because you already did
your run then you did ch
then you ate chat and you took a shower
eat chow and then you had to go back to
your barracks you know
and wait for first formation well that
might be an
hour right there so you if you ate fast
you could get back to the barracks and
get another hour's sleep
because sometimes you were only running
on a couple hours you know because
you're a partying or working or
doing missions you know just infantry
[ __ ]
so you wanted to skip that part of the
morning where you're
sitting down in the chow hall eating you
just wanted to take the food off the
damn tray and walk out with it
and go back to your room you couldn't
take the tray back to the barracks
so we would do [ __ ] like order a western
omelet
all right and then go and get some bacon
and then get some pan and then get like
one pancake that was self-serve
all right and what you and then on your
tray you take the omelet
and put that on top of the the uh uh
the pancake put your bacon and ham on
top of the almond and roll it up like a
burrito
and then throw the damn tray into the
cleaning bin right there where they
clean it and walk out with it
yeah it's like a breakfast sandwich and
you might even have a couple of hash
browns
in there with jelly on top as well with
grape jelly
in that mix too because
one of the great things about american
breakfast food is that if it mixes
together it actually all tastes
better you can mix everything
yeah i can't really think of any
american classic american breakfast food
that doesn't taste good with all the
other
yeah ones you could take two
you could take two um flapjacks or
pancakes
throw bacon and eggs in between them put
maple syrup on and eat that
yeah okay it tastes great because it's
all it
normally it would be side by side kind
of mixing in together anyway
now i kind of want to make that so now
you just kind of yeah we were doing cool
[ __ ] like that
with it so it's kind of like the
ultimate
fast food now one thing in my research
i've noticed that is that
out of all of the amer all of the
american foods you can even probably
include
probably the english breakfast too but
out of everything that we have
what seems to be most appealing and most
acceptable to foreigners from
totally alien culinary practices
they like that breakfast you can give
that to somebody in turkey and they'd
like it you could give it to somebody in
saudi arabia and they'd like it
you could give it to somebody in china
and they would eat that japan would eat
that
because they're just kind of i guess
because they're very
simple kind of they're not an overly
prepared food it's a lot of whole foods
so they're familiar with it
and it blends real well i've noticed
that
foreigners are really impressed with um
maple syrup if they've never had it
especially if it's hot interesting you
would think that that would be
we take it for granted yeah but they're
like oh man this is great what is this
it's from a tree you know that's the
kind of
this is really good they'll pour that on
french toast
you know oh yeah they like all that oh
man
no you could take we used to take
we had french toast in the army too we
and it was in whole
pieces you know like a whole slice of
french toast yeah you put ham
and eggs and cheese and make a sandwich
like that
get some jelly and walk out with it and
it was kind of like a monte cristo
sandwich yeah
yeah all right what do they call it in
france a croque monsieur
i don't know that's like basically a ham
and cheese sandwich like right ham and
cheese sandwich
we throw egg in it too we're trying to
get as much food as we could oh yeah
with some bacon and everything so it was
like a giant
mutant hillbilly [ __ ] hillbilly
version of the damn of the [ __ ]
of the the sandwich i forgot what
sandwich it was
i mean the nice thing too is that even
though some you have like your kind of
more sweeter
things like pancakes and waffles and
stuff like i said with maple syrup but
that tastes that tastes really good with
the savory [ __ ] too
yeah like so you get like a little bit
of everything yeah
so if you here's here's the other thing
if
i if you're living in another country
and you want to experiment
with american food it's best to start
with with um
breakfast because you could probably get
pretty much all of that
in your location i mean
sod even he he he lives in saudi arabia
and they were selling maple syrup in the
grocery store yeah so you can
a lot of some a lot of american stuff
has kind of become globalized
where you can get it on a global market
now it's kind of catching on
but if you wanted to cook american food
probably
for the first time it'd probably be
easiest to start with breakfast
and you get a good taste of what it is
that we eat over here
um it's uh
now if you're gonna mess with breakfast
i mean and you don't know how to cook
you might as well start practicing
because uh there's a skill in there that
every cook has to learn and you learn it
in culinary school
and that's how to cook an egg all right
and there's all kinds of video tutorials
on how to cook eggs
on a non-stick pan or even just a
greased pan
and uh then the next step is how to beat
eggs and how to
make cook an omelette uh my best
uh my best advice for to like a novice
cook
is to have a tool that i like to use
called an egg flipper
it's a special kind of uh it's a special
kind of uh
spatula i have three of them it's shaped
like a knife
basically like a big kitchen knife but
it's rubber and it's like a
it's like a spatula blade and it helps
you do things like
flip eggs over or fold on an omelette
up and close an omelette uh but it's
also real good at emptying bowls
have the right equipment you know what i
mean if you get in there you're trying
to cook eggs and you cut you got a
shitty little spatula you're gonna have
trouble you know get the right stuff
yeah i mean you really need the
non-stick pans too because i used to
have like old shitty pans and cooking
eggs was like such a [ __ ] they would
always stick
yeah you have to have the temperature
right if you don't have nonstick
yeah and there has to be oil in the pan
so a lot of times you're cooking
bacon first and then the bacon drippings
is what the egg's gonna be cooked in
because cooking time on an egg is far
faster than bacon is okay
and um the american breakfast
actually if you're especially if you're
dealing with cast iron
which is tradition that's where it would
go back a lot of that stuff is cooked in
cat on
cast iron griddles or they were on cast
iron skillets
um it's a lot of times one pan
uh it's a one pan production you're
cooking it all in the same pan
in the in the order the meat the the
bacon ends up
grease in the pan that's what the hash
browns are gonna get
cooked in and then finally the eggs and
you're kind of taking it out of there as
you go
now there's some stuff that i've done in
the past
just for to make things eagle easy
and that's preparing a quick breakfast
with everything that would be in an
american breakfast all in a single pan
yeah okay together like you would take
bacon
fry the bacon all right when the bacon
gets almost done
just crack eggs on top of the damn bacon
and let it all cook together
flip all that over put cheese on one
side of it
then take that out and put that in a
bowl and eat it
real good it's like it's like an
omelette it's just that it's not folded
it's all together do the same thing with
thin slices of spam
cook in the spam then put something like
jalapenos or vegetables or
uh peppers on it and then pouring like
six eggs or four eggs depending on how
how big your pan is and how hungry you
are
and just letting it cook in that pan
with the meat on top of it it works fine
and then flip that and then top it with
cheese cover it and steam it all
together
yeah called the frittata it probably is
i think
yeah it probably is there's probably a
name for it because nothing's original
yeah all right it's just if you're
if you tried if you if you're trying to
cook for speed and ease of cooking
that's something that cook would just
automatically kind of do let's just cook
this all at once
in the same pan together and it's great
really good
you could take that and throw that on
top of a pancake
and put syrup on it and eat it eggs
pork syrup pancakes yeah man all in the
same fork
it works peppers and everything the guy
i was watching earlier he actually had
made some bacon and then he cut it up
into little pieces and he put it on the
flat top and then he put the pancake
batter
yeah over it so that when you flipped it
over it had like bacon like integrated
yep he also put jalapenos in the waffle
batter
yeah jalapenos is very good in uh egg in
eggs
or like waffle batter heard about that
yeah yeah he made that and then he put
like chicken on top of it and then he
poured maple syrup over top it looks
delicious our jalapenos are they're
they're they're pickled
and in a slightly vinegary type of
solution but it's very hot almost kind
of like tabasco sauce i don't waste it
oh like i buy big things of
like a big jar or this big jar with that
juice i'm going to use that juice in
something
i'll pour it in something let it cook
down in it and
but anyway um that
tart and hot ness that's inside
or the vinegary and hotness of that um
jalapeno that we have works really well
with sweet
yeah you wouldn't think it would but it
does
so i could see that working real well in
um
in a waffle yeah with uh maple syrup on
it and like i said he had chicken fried
chicken
fried chicken it was like a chicken and
waffles application hell yeah
that'd be real good goddamn chicken wine
i know tell them about chicken and
waffles jun
[Laughter]
yeah we get chicken and waffles at uh
chantelle's although
as many times as i've got that there
like after the club i have never
been able to finish it it's just too
much even if i haven't eaten all day
it's a big ass waffle like this big
and three pieces of fried chicken on top
of it it's a a leg
a thigh and a breast yep and they're
deep fried
on the bone you put it on top of the
waffle and you pour
syrup on all of it you think well how
the hell do you eat that
you just take a knife and take your fork
and stick it through the chicken
cut it off of the chicken and then cut
the the uh
the waffle the waffle underneath it and
there'll be syrup on there and you eat
it all at once it's [ __ ] great real
good
yeah really good butter and syrup on it
or some people put honey on it too which
is kind of the same thing yeah honey and
helena maple syrup on that application
pretty similar yeah
the the thing is is that there's only
one thing against
chicken and waffles is that deep frying
chicken
it's a long cooking time and and prep is
long you got to make you got to make a
egg wash
you have to get your flour ready and
seasoned
and you got to batter the chicken and
fry it and cook in time because
20 something minutes you know so
for breakfast that's kind of a long
project
yeah most people want breakfast done
quickly
so you could say that chicken and
waffles would be like an
extra deluxe breakfast that's like
almost like a brunch thing yeah
that takes long time longer to do that
if you're gonna go sit and have like
have a couple mimosas and not care about
how long it takes
it's not the kind of situation where you
woke up the crack of dawn you gotta feed
all three of these [ __ ] man
okay this is what's gonna happen because
uh it's uh
once you get your skills down you can
feed four or five people with an
american breakfast quickly
you know within 30 minutes yeah yeah no
problem and it's like and it's really
cheap too
yeah and you know even making all the
[ __ ] is like you know if you're making
all the [ __ ]
and that's the thing one of my favorite
things about
uh back in the day about staying in
hotels was the breakfast buffet
yeah because every single thing on there
is good and so i would just go and
get like a little bit of every single
thing but [ __ ] man
yeah somebody was talking about uh grits
what about
uh like i don't know i'm catching up
asking i'm catching up with the i'm
catching up with the
with the comment section i mean honestly
my my favorite
simple go-to meal like and i used to
just not just for breakfast
i used to have because i worked at night
and i'd get home like about four in the
morning
and then i would need some dinner or
breakfast or whatever it was four in the
morning
uh and i would just make a couple fried
eggs and
a little bit of bacon and some toast and
that was just like that was
perfectly good it took like takes like
five ten minutes to make
and it's pretty nutritious i guess
but you know pov saying he's gonna go
out and try some new trigger i don't
know which trigger you're talking about
i don't know that one
i got a k.e arms mr roboto asks
do we have do we got waffle house yeah
yeah there's a couple waffle houses
around
they tore a lot of them down though yeah
is that one still there that we used to
go to all the time
the one that was by your old house yeah
yeah we used to go there all the time
but for a while we don't we'd always go
to denny's like after the club
because you'd always want a grand slam i
mean i don't always want a grand slam
because for i i mean i really like
see that that's the thing it's like it
kind of sucks because i always get up
really early but i don't really get
hungry until later so usually i just
have a cup of coffee and that's it i
don't usually eat any breakfast
sometimes i'll have like a bowl of
oatmeal but that's about all i can
stomach that early in the morning
but i mean it i really really
like just the idea of like just a big
huge
breakfast even if i can't eat it's like
you know what i mean it's just like
pancakes waffles french toast
eggs bacon all that [ __ ] grits
i mean that's like my favorite one of my
favorite things
badgers in there saying i still need to
make grits
if you've never made grits prepare if
you make grits just a plain way
just with salt and pepper and butter on
them there's not much to them
we like to season them i like to put
tony sachery's cajun seasoning or any
kind of cajun seasoning that you find to
be all right
probably tony's i think is the best one
um put a little bit of cajun seasoning
in it
uh crumbled up bits of bacon or
chopped ham maybe yeah that works too
yeah you want it kinda
if you're gonna put ham in there precook
the ham a little bit get it a little bit
brown before you put it in there
and then um take some cheddar cheese
grate it put some grated cheddar cheese
in it and stir it
it'll all mix up in there if it starts
getting too thick and pasty put a little
bit of cream or milk in it to loosen it
back up again
you want it to be kind of creamy chantel
would say put
coconut milk in it and i wouldn't
disagree with her that's what she does
yeah yeah cause their shrimp and grits
are like out of this world
yeah that's another thing if you don't
want to go through all that just get you
some
shrimp if you can find pre-cooked
deveined frozen shrimp that'd actually
be good enough yeah
um uh make sure the thawed uh and cook
if it's pre-cooked then you just thought
uh put them in put that in the grits let
it heat up
put that in there with some cajun
seasoning yeah
same thing the actually cheese would be
good with it
and then loosened it up with uh some
cream yeah cause hers had cheese in it
yeah here's that cheese in it yeah
she used coconut milk yeah yeah instead
of cream that's what made it yeah it
made it really really like
velvety but there's a lot of recipes
online for that
just don't get some basic bitch-ass
grits
i mean that's what they gave us in the
army and they didn't stay basic for long
we were throwing all kinds of stuff in
those grits
yeah they you kind of have to put i mean
i i like them with just like butter and
black pepper in them like i can eat them
like that
but you can't just eat them plain really
you need to put stuff in there you need
to put some kind of seasoning
a [ __ ] ton of butter some cheese we put
whole
uh hard-boiled eggs in ours yeah whole
hard-boiled eggs that way you can kind
of like
with a spoon slice off a little bit of
hard-boiled egg and get it with the
grits and you have the
eggs in the center of it yeah just
whatever
um but yeah she's she's the basic is
just
salt pepper and butter some people
really like that that's like
yeah that's the way i want mine i want
my old old school style
yeah that's like some [ __ ] my dad would
do i used to eat them like that yeah
some people like that but
you get tired of them if you ask me
depends just try it
you need to pimp them out yeah i pimp
them out tom has to pimp everything
up we we can't ever eat anything like
just simple food he has to like
he has to like but he has to bling it
all off he has to
keep putting like more and more stuff in
it you know um
some of the stuff that i like to make it
needs bacon bits cooking bacon is a
[ __ ] uh it's just an extra step that
you have to do
and recently i've seen these i've been
buying these bags
of real pre-made bacon bits they've got
a zip lock on top of them
they have them at sam's that whole bag
is i think it's about 11 bucks
it's worth it it's it's kind of
expensive for
you know for the poundage of how much
bacon it is but the speed at which you
can
turn a dish out has increased a lot
because you can just say well it's like
a side component it's not the main
feature of the dish
like uh i made a i was making
cheeseburgers last night
and i said oh i got those bacon bits and
then took two spoons
full of those bacon bits and put them on
top of the cheese on top of cheeseburger
and then just put the lid on the pan and
steamed them in there
man that [ __ ] was good man yeah it was a
lot faster than pulling out
four strips of bacon and cooking it
separately and then having to deal with
the damn
bacon drippings and what i'm gonna do
the bacon drippings you know you can't
cook it in the same pan but
cooking time is a little different
sometimes you you think of these things
well
in our inopportune times well you know
bacon would be good on that
i can't cook bacon but if i had bacon
i'd use it and go i do have bacon
that's the kind of the well yeah so
we've been putting bacon bits on pretty
much everything yeah
burger salads yeah it's mostly a salad
thing yeah but it is a real bacon bit
and um yeah it's not like this weird
it's not yeah it's not a fake bake it's
a real bacon bit the fake
faking bits so i'm just paying for the
convenience
oh yeah which that's you know that's
legit and again
you can make a real fast bacon and
cheese omelette
and it's real good for breakfast stuff
you know
i like it i mean to be honest omelettes
i know like i know this is going to be
like sacrilegious i love bacon i'm not
saying that and i love
i love all the breakfast meats you know
i love sausage i love ham all that kind
of stuff
but honestly if i'm making an omelette i
would rather just have like uh veggies
in there
yeah mushrooms tomatoes yeah she likes
vegetable stuff i like red peppers
yeah like they're good with meat in them
like you know ham and cheese and stuff
but
i don't know i like it i like a good
mushroom yeah omelet
you know suit everybody just mushroom
maybe a little bit of spinach in there
yummy [ __ ] says he's got a lot of times
on his hands coming up he'll
he's going to try a bunch of different
variants gramster's hammer says why do
the grits at waffle house taste like dry
snot
i just think they don't they don't
season them enough
you know what i mean i don't know what
they do to them i didn't usually get
grits at waffle house we usually got
we usually got biscuits and gravy or um
or i get you know waffles yeah now louie
louie louie hernandez went ahead and
mentioned he says
mexican breakfast must have salsa in it
there are some real good mexican
breakfasts
that they eat huevos rancheros which is
just
eggs with that salsa yeah and i'm sure
they
they're trying they dress that up in a
bunch of different ways too
but i remember in california i first saw
huevos what ontario's it was good
it was real good um another thing that
they'll do is that they'll
they'll take scrambled eggs and some
cheese and put that in a
in a tortilla shell corn tortilla
it's kind of like an egg taco mmm you
like tacos yeah
yeah i mean they have breakfast burritos
here so it's kind of like the same thing
like that
right man i love a good breakfast
burrito yeah
although i think the breakfast burrito i
don't i think the breakfast breakfast
burritos that we're eating of course you
know i think that's an american i think
yeah that's more an american invention
although
that's something that that mexicans
would eat flour tortilla with some eggs
and cheese and some meat
yeah that's not that different than they
probably put some salsa in it what you
know priced tomato sauce well most
people here puts all things green
green tomatoes green salsa maybe
you have to ask louie yeah i'm just i'm
interested in what other cultures eat
for breakfast you know what i mean it's
like there's
and and why i'm always kind of curious
too like why certain things are
considered breakfast food and certain
things
are considered not that's obviously a
cultural thing
yeah because some place like for example
i know there are some countries where
people eat soup for breakfast and here
if you did that everyone would think you
were a weirdo even though there's no
reason in the world
why you can't eat soup for breakfast
cereal is kind of like soup when you
think about it
yeah you know but i
i think people maybe have a perception
that americans just eat sweet things for
breakfast like donuts and
big ass muffins and stuff like that
which some
which people do but i don't know i'm
kind of more
sometimes i'm in the mood for more sweet
things like waffles or pancakes or
something usually i want something
savory i want something with eggs or
you know but like i said normally that's
i kind of like that late at night though
like aft after
if i'm drunk i usually want breakfast
food
waffles or eggs or something
they're near talking about that green
that green uh salsa that green mexican
salsa
they used to have that at publix
in the import section and they would
sell it
in a two liter plastic container
huge two liter plastic container that
stuff
for like only uh three or four bucks
i was buying it it was looking great i
don't think it was mexican though
i think it was i think it was further
south it might have been from salvador
or something
maybe honduras it was good really good
some people were calling it some people
call it that green enchilada sauce but
it's it's tomato
salsa it's green tomato sauce is what it
is
it's good yeah that'd make a real good
uh salsa for eggs like some kind of
some kind of a mexican breakfast burrito
that's what i'd put in it
louis says louise says we eat menudo for
breakfast which is a tripe soup
yeah that [ __ ] boy it's just strong too
friend of mine was cooking that up in
the barracks he had that
he had a can he had a big old can of it
his mom sent it to him
oh man they sent me the oh man i'm gonna
have it today he put that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ]
maybe he's ramen get this little
electric cooker
and because this menu he goes hey yeah
man this is good it was chaffino
miguel he's heating it up because man
this is going to be so good you want
something that says yeah i take a little
bit of it
it started to get hot and i was like oh
man never mind i don't want anything
because it's good though you're going to
like it i tasted some of it it didn't
taste bad it's just a disrupt that was
uh
definitely internal organs yeah you know
it had it had that internal organ taste
to it it was like
it was it was like chili kinda yeah you
know
it kind of had chili style spices
it was uh it was it was rough you know i
was like nah you can keep it man i don't
want to eat up your
with you know your gift from home you
know that's up in korea
he's eating menudo and [ __ ] cookies i
don't know i mean
i know everyone's like digestive systems
are different but it's just kind of like
i can't
face eating something like that
something that
um strong or something that heavy like
that early in the morning
he was just eating it like like soup
i was thinking man shouldn't that go on
rice and he's like no
and he's just eating it like this no i
know what i'm doing
yeah i would have mixed that like half
and half of rice
it would have made more sense to me it
didn't
it didn't taste like stew to me but i
would put rice and stew i put rice and
stew
you know yeah yeah yeah my grandma used
to yeah
mr rabata says leek soup and fish for
breakfast that actually sounds kind of
good i really like leek soup
to be honest with you i had it a lot in
wales
um you know and fish for breakfast
that's never louis said it was something
required taste well yeah yeah yeah
it's just i don't know i so so i feel
like
i mean when i was on vacation um i told
myself i'm actually going to get up and
like have
breakfast because i never really get to
or i never really feel like it when i'm
at home
but even then i one day i went and had
kind of like a big
like a big breakfast i had like uh some
grits with hot sauce on them and like
some
bacon and eggs and stuff and that was
really good but the rest of the time i
was just
like you know i'd have like one time i
had the little piece of quiche lorraine
and then one time i had
one time i woke up and i was like man i
want a croissant yeah so i had to go
down to this there's a place called
chocolate is it's down there and they
have all like croissants and [ __ ] like
that
yeah and just had that with just some
jelly on it
but if you guys have never had any
american food you know if you're in a
foreign country
you want to try the breakfast first i
mean it's it's the most friendly
because it's mostly whole foods and
mostly
easy to get components that are
available in most
parts of the world so there's nothing
anything and
there's nothing strange in there the
strangest thing would be that them
maple syrup in some countries that's
very expensive but people
universally seem to like it no matter
where they are um
a good example would be uh i was in here
eating
on one show i showed pecan pie to the
camera
and assad up in saudi arabia says oh man
that looks good
so he started he he dm'd me and he and
he was like what's in that well he said
no he saw the
he saw the um yeah he asked me how i
made it and i showed him the recipe
and then he and i said you i said you'll
like this this is all
within the arabic flavor palette because
you know a lot of their sweets are
similar to that and he's like yeah that
does yeah
it's really sweet but it's good yeah and
middle eastern sweets are very sweet
yeah and they like things like nuts and
they like
things that are kind of molasses-y type
things you know it's
candied sweet and um
so he goes down he and saudi arabia had
corn syrup okay and on the cover
or on the label of the corn syrup it had
a pitcher of pecan pie
oh yeah yeah yeah all right the thing is
is that he got that on his second one
the first one he used it wasn't it was
he used something arabic and it didn't
set
so it tasted like corn syrup but it
wasn't quite thick enough
that's what he used i i have to remember
exactly the order of vince
so it comes out of the oven he shows me
a picture it looks good he cuts it and
it just
because it didn't didn't set he ate it
anyway he goes this is good that's still
good
even if you [ __ ] it up it's still good a
couple days later he shows me
shows me the picture of that label of of
of corn syrup
i think it was corn syrup it was either
corn syrup or maple syrup one of the two
but on the on the label it was all
written in arabic
on the label it had a picture of pecan
pie
that's really horny that's really funny
pouring it out onto a
onto a raw pecan pie before it's baked
yeah
i think it might have been maple syrup
though because you can use either
yeah yeah it's either maple syrup creams
or i
i'll have to ask him again it might have
been corn syrup but that's not what he
used he used the wrong thing for the
first one
well you know yeah although like you
said it was still good it was still good
but um esther said i like crepes for
breakfast
that's not weird she said i'm weird no
that's not weird that's not weird at all
i love crepes
yeah an american would say that that's a
breakfast food yeah i don't think the
french would think so
i don't think it's as common and like i
said you can get them uh
sweet or savory and it's actually in st
augustine i didn't get to go there but
there's a whole like uh
cafe like a brunch place that's
completely based around crepes
yeah a pancake is a hillbilly crepe it's
the same pretty much
it's just so this is and when i make
pancakes i like really thin crepe lick
right and you can do that too i mean i
like big fluffy pancakes too but i kind
of prefer them like thinner
yeah trace render says
is it popular in america put to put a
knob of cheese on blueberry pie
no i've seen cheddar cheese on apple pie
um not so much blueberry i'm sure people
do it but
i think apple pie i i've never i've only
done it once or twice but i think they
put cheddar cheese on apple pie do they
not
yeah well we have a couple different
kinds of apple pie yeah some apple pie
you wouldn't do that too
yeah like the kind of apple pie i forgot
forgot what the name of it is
set my mind the one that has the uh the
sugar crumble on top of it
yeah not supposed to put cheese on that
that's like an apple pan dowdy or like
yeah something like that
the one you put the cheese on is the
apple pie that has the lattice worked
out the loudest
stuff on it like the classic classic
apple pie right yeah
yeah i've seen yeah i've seen people put
cheddar cheese on top of that but i mean
maybe they do it with blueberry too i
don't know i don't eat a lot of
blueberry
i had never heard of that but maybe yeah
i don't really know
uh louis said anybody ever has barbacoa
for breakfast
never heard of it um yeah traditional
apple pie is great with cheese yeah it
is good but cheese i mean i kind of just
prefer plain but you know
um i saw something else that i was gonna
but um for you guys out there man i'm
i'm happy that you like the series i'm
happy that um
that me talking about this is getting
guys
to want to cook things for the very
first time and
for the best yeah and i like that i like
i like to uh i like to quote
my uncle uh putin uh he was in front of
a bunch of students and the
these macho ass russian kids are like
so what do we do to make us more macho
more masculine i think they were [ __ ]
with him and [ __ ] putin goes
learn how to cook they all laugh and he
goes no i'm serious
and puts us you learn how to cook what
are you going to do all right you're
going to
you're going to keep running to your
mama and have her cook you things learn
how to feed yourself learn how to feed
other people it's a skill that you'll
you'll have for the rest of your life
and you'll you'll never go hungry when
you when you know how to go
honestly it is really one of the most
useful skills yeah because
you got to eat you got to eat you know
right and there's some cultures where
cooking is women's work so or so they
say
yeah although when you actually look at
the cultures that believe that it's not
really what was happening
you know what i mean like traditional
arabic culture
yeah women did housework and stuff that
most traditional
cultures did that but men cooked also
yeah even
even in bedouin culture you know what i
mean they're barbecuing things
underneath the ground and
making fires and everybody cooked this
is it
and so one of the most macho
[ __ ] in the world right now
gordon [ __ ] ramsay is a cook
yeah and he's like something out of down
special forces
at least his mouth is right i'm not sure
about the red stuff
yeah he's tough you know but it's all
you're [ __ ] like it's burned it's
wrong
oh yeah yeah well
kitchens are high pressure environments
it's very [ __ ] hot there's a lot of
floor planning and teamwork it's a lot
like cross between a dam
air traffic control tower and um
or an old-school air traffic control
tower now i think it's all computers
but back on the date was dudes [ __ ]
trying to keep track of all these planes
uh so it's like a cross between air
traffic controllers and rock stars
they're kind of like the rock stars of
the of the blue collar world
running around with waitresses and
getting in trouble and
they all party cook's party
well yeah that's a big part of the
culture a lot of them would fall to
drugs
yeah to try to stay awake because
they're after getting off of work
[ __ ] partying
and uh going to damn strip clubs or
just whatever with the whole staff
you know and dating chasing the
waitresses and dating waitresses and
then they got to get up first thing in
the morning they're out there drinking
all night and then they get it get up
first thing in the morning and [ __ ]
get the kitchen ready
yeah and you know it's a hard job
sliding into chemical assistance to get
all this done
yeah and then it's bad road it's a bad
road you know what i mean [ __ ]
they're they're aware of it though you
know a lot of these kitchens are aware
of it today
and they keep an eye out for that and if
somebody
looks like they're sliding they'll try
to get him help in a good kitchen
you know yeah because like i said it's a
you know it's like an occupational
hazard yeah it's occupational either
somebody brought up eggs benedict before
yeah and i wanted to say something too i
was watching
a guy i think he's called sam the
cooking guy i've never seen him before
but i just kind of
came across it on youtube and he had a
trick for eggs benedict and i didn't
actually know that you could do this
but he's like if you're making eggs
benedict like for brunch and for a bunch
of people and you don't want to
be like stressed out like trying to
poach the eggs while everybody's
there um he's like you can totally poach
them ahead of time
it's like just poach them put them in
ice water like in a he had him in a like
a container with ice water
and he's like and then he's like i did
these like an hour ago and he's like and
then when you're
going to go in to make the eggs benedict
you just like pop it back in simmer
like simmering water for like a minute
and it comes out completely perfect
yeah i i think i vaguely remember that
and i was like oh that's a good tip
caterers do that because honestly i mean
poaching an egg is kind of a pain in the
ass yeah i
hate it it's just it's really easy to
[ __ ] it up
there's little cups for it and another
way to do is you can stir a pot real
hard like that and then drop an egg in
the middle of the vortex
and and if the water temperature's right
it'll
i don't know i mean don't make me say
don't don't make me say that the word
whirlpool i say the word world i say the
word
whirlpool and some of these guys in
there want to rock up because they think
i'm talking about
because i remember i said that that girl
was dragging him into the world
they instantly knew what i was talking
about
or a whirlpoon if you will oh yeah
i got that from um a
a a mansion in um
in a roman history of a very popular
roman prostitute one of those brothels
down there in pompeii
and her business name was whirlpool
that's what the book said whirlpool so i
was trying to imagine that
i was going okay so that concept goes
back that far
yeah but ah don't let me get graphic
i were they talking about a hip action
to do
doing this or did she have some kind of
special skill
why not both or both it was something
that was stood the test of time
her name was recorded in roman history
and uh
she was a very special lady she was
very special exactly i'm going to write
that [ __ ] down with whirlpool
we call her scylla and charybdas yeah
yeah but uh
uh yeah grantha's hammer says kitchen
confidential by uh anthony bourdain went
into great detail about cooks and
alcohol and drugs
yeah i should read that one of these
days yeah yeah yeah he passed away
yeah uh yeah i mean grandparents grant
us when
i was going to treton high i worked uh
my first cooking job was down the street
at that bar and grill
just out from the school you know like
where where i forgot the name of the
place you know [ __ ]
it's been so long but that place was
[ __ ] jumping and i started off as a
dishwasher
and uh all those cooks in there they
were
all those cooks and they were [ __ ]
fantastic they were really good
and they were all [ __ ] on something
yeah
all of them just because of the damn
pressure
there was they're constantly cooking
constantly working
then they had they only have a few hours
at the end of the night for any kind of
social life and it's usually some kind
of intense partying
and alcohol and then they got to get up
the next morning
and do that [ __ ] all over again and
they're kind of having fun
while they're working but they're also
under a lot of stress and they were
young they were all in their
late 20s early 30s they're chasing girls
and stuff
they were [ __ ] a riot man and uh then
later on i was
did a lot of the short order stuff and
the prep stuff and making desserts and
um making components that they were
using they were real cooks they
they weren't opening bags and just you
know heating [ __ ]
heating [ __ ] up you know from cisco they
weren't doing that they were making
stuff
one day i sat there and made french
fries all [ __ ] day
i had to peel potatoes and put them
through the french fry maker and i was
making big 55 gallon damn
oil drums plastic drums and [ __ ]
french fries
all in water pouring sugar in them and
salt
it's wild man every day i was doing some
soak them in sugar water that's what
makes them good yeah sugar water with a
little bit of salt
and um they had all that [ __ ] they
they do weird things like [ __ ] be
carving up a big old piece of beef and
makings you know they were almost like
butchers too they could get steaks out
of [ __ ] the side of a beef
you know because it's a lot cheaper just
to buy a [ __ ] horse
well yeah side of beef and start getting
cuts off of it and then
[ __ ] that wasn't going [ __ ] it wasn't
sellable they reached in and grabbed a
[ __ ] raw piece of beef and started
chewing on it and eating it
something goes oh it's good man tartare
you want me this and i was like i'm
gonna be a [ __ ] i'm like yeah
and i get somebody that started eating
it they were looking at me laughing like
you're trying to impress us
you know they're [ __ ] with me you
know that was a high school kid
i don't know granters remembers the name
of that grampur's hammer says uncle
ben's
is that it might have been he said i
worked across the street at jerry's
butcher shop
yeah he said my mom and dad met at uncle
ben's in nineteen seventies
yeah that's where i was and that's
probably where they got that beef
they're probably getting it from the
butcher's shop across the street
trace render brings up steak and eggs oh
yeah yeah
i haven't had steak and eggs for a
really long time yeah that is also a
really good breakfast
somebody uh miguel says what is a good
camping breakfast
i mean anything honestly i can't for
camping
yeah i like taking [ __ ] camping okay
cans of spam i like the flavored spam
there's a lot of good different flavors
so it's small a lot a lot of uh
it's um high concentrated
protein all right it started off as a
combat ration really when you think
about it
world war ii was [ __ ] spam powered
but the the new low sodium versions are
a lot tastier because the original
recipe was [ __ ] salty as [ __ ] oh yeah
the low sodiums are better i really like
the jalapeno ones i like the bacon
flavor one
uh i haven't had the turkey yet but i
own some the smoked is good
slice that off did put it in a pan
fry both sides of it and then get
powdered eggs
mix that up with the water and pour that
over it and just let it turn into like a
like an omelette and then flip it or you
could take the meat out and just make an
omelet and put it and then cube it and
put it inside there use all kind of
creative things
you could do but i recommend powdered
eggs and spam
that'd be a good breakfast that you
could you can camp with that
um powdered milk too take that along
now if you have a vacuum sealer get some
heavy duty plastic
things and and seal it and vacuum if
they're cheap you can get them off ebay
of 20 30 bucks
start vacuum sealing containers
of powdered milk powdered eggs do it in
like
you know like four or five eggs six egg
packs
that way it'll feed your whole party or
three people every owning
every opening it's light you know and
as long as you have the ability to
collect water when you're camping and
filtering it then you'll be able to
have milk and eggs which is important
which be important components to cooking
anything really
you can also have powdered butter
that's out there uh and you can vacuum
seal that
and you'd use that for like uh you could
add water to it
and uh use it as a spread probably
wouldn't taste that good but it'd be
like a
a good oil to cook things in like on a
pan
because you can't carry butter around a
stick of butter
you know and
camping especially if you're on foot
things that are hydrated
way more i used to like making like
camping donuts
you know what i mean you make those
donuts over the fire you can do that
with like that
pillsbury biscuit though or they have
those
big cartons of dehydrated
um hashbrowns yeah
you could take some of that and put that
in a plastic bag and
and and vacuum pack it and pack that
along too
take that out in the field just add
water to it it
turns back into potatoes yeah we use
that a lot actually
yeah it's not ready to eat though you
have to cook it yeah but you would have
raw potatoes yeah and you have to cook
them
it didn't take long to cook though yeah
yeah miguel said sugar water
i need to try that yeah that's kind of
the secret of uh good french fries
yeah i'm pretty sure mcdonald's does
that yeah i learned that from my brother
because he worked there a long time ago
and the secret to um
chick-fil-a sandwiches the reason why
they're so good
is because they take those chicken
breasts and they soak them for
at least overnight and dill pickle juice
yep yeah and we've done the same thing
it tastes just like that yeah
you take it out and then you dunk it in
egg wash
and then uh roll it through seasoned
flour
you put it in a pressure cooker with a
little bit of oil i think it was yeah
oil
and pressure cook it for only a couple
minutes uh you can find out online what
it is
and it'll come out that in
the old school that's the way they used
to do it at chick-fil-a now they do it
with
without the oil i think it's baked is it
baked or something oh i don't know i
tried to reduce the calories
but originally it was uh battered
and pressure cooked in oil yeah in a
pressure cooker only for a couple
minutes
and when it comes out man it's [ __ ]
good really good
you just put it on a on like a
a dinner roll style
hamburger bun a steamed hamburger bun is
what what it is
and it's not even a real nice one or
didn't used to be it was just like kind
of like a cheap one
yeah yeah but yeah now i
now i want a big ass breakfast food yeah
maybe we should have that for dinner
[Laughter]
i got that pizza dough i got to use i
have okay i have cakes i have cakes of
real um buffalo mozzarella cheese
okay well we'll have pizza then yeah and
that dough is aged
we had pizza last night too because well
yeah because the kids came over
yeah yesterday after the kids they came
over yesterday afternoon so we made a
bunch of pizzas to feed everybody
so we still have a bunch of dough left
over because that's the thing when he
makes dough or sauce he makes like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of it
so we can just whip up a pizza at a
moment's notice we're out of mushrooms
though aren't we yeah
[ __ ] i ate the rest we can get some more
yeah i think it was called
uncle ben's grill i think it was not
like uncle ben's rice
no it was uh it was like a a bar and
grill
that had um kind of like a 70s style
tacky bar kind of in the front
dark but that's just the way they were
in the 70s and it had a um
a grill and it was [ __ ] great food
man it was great food
not just because i worked there i was
eating that [ __ ] and i was going man
this shit's looking good
see that's how you know the restaurant's
good if like the people that work there
still eat there
yeah after all that time yeah it just
looked like it looked like a kind of
place you'd see like a mafiosi kind of
[ __ ] hanging out yeah man
i know yeah i know because there's like
those dark 70s yeah
yeah you seen your suit where yeah you
still see some restaurants that look
like that on like kitchen nightmares and
stuff
yeah prepper's asking where will you be
selling your book it'll be on the
bookstore on
lulu and i think that they do uh
extended
i don't know if they i don't know if
they do amazon or if they maybe do
barnes and noble i'm not really sure
i don't know we'll see hopefully the
proof gets here soon because it's not
male 1 he's saying it was either uncle
ben's or mr nix
oh okay i kind of want to think it was
uncle ben's
hmm i don't know i just can't help you i
just would call it the grill
i gotta go to the grill
i gotta go to the grill well the people
that work there just called it the grill
[Laughter]
oh camp guy said i've worked in food
service and i would like to walk through
the kitchen at any restaurant i'm about
to eat it
and estro said breakfast pizza is big
here in philadelphia
yeah i kind of heard that that was a big
thing not so much i mean you can get it
here i think
but i don't really i've never had it
and i don't know anyone that's had it
but i mean i'm pretty sure you can get
it though
somewhere yeah but i heard that was kind
of more like a pennsylvania thing
i don't know i'd totally eat it i'm not
hating
[Laughter]
yes and i think you're right it was
peanut oil
they cooked that chicken in peanut oil
yeah yeah
okay yeah and it's pressure cooked and
it'll give the batter a weird texture
it's that exact same texture that you
got from the old school yeah
chick-fil-a because i used to yeah we
used to have one
in our old mall in dayton it's probably
still there i don't know
i've been a dayton a long time but
that's usually where i ate x that's what
was closest to my house
it might have been nick's bar and grill
it might have been nick's
he said it's the same place that changed
names at some point yeah it might have
been nick's at the time i was there
i think i would have remembered uncle
ben's it sounds real familiar but
there's that rice
yeah i think it might have been nick's
grill at the time when i was there
but we would just say man i gotta go
work at the grill
man i gotta go gotta shift at the grill
don the vaughn says tom how was your
birthday
that was good yeah my birthdays are
always good
because i'm alive when i stop showing up
for my own birthdays
that's a good way of looking at it
that's a good way of looking at it yeah
xanada said
something about breakfast pizza yeah i
had it in minnesota it's a yankee thing
like wait okay what's on it though is it
like a pizza crust
with like eggs and [ __ ] on it or
i mean because i would eat that i'm not
gonna lie would it do they have like
sauce
or because that seems like it may be
weird
hold on no camp guy olive oil actually
has like
the smoke point is real low on it all
right the highest one the one
the oil that can take the most abuse was
castor oil
that's why i used to put it in damn
aircraft engines
uh it's [ __ ] and evidently it [ __ ]
tasted bad but
uh and it did weird [ __ ] under
compression you'd
the back of the damn evidently you could
see a whole bomber formation from
from the rear at night when they were
flying in world war ii at least an
american one
because you just see all these little
things that like sparkles
and it was uh castor oil burning inside
the dam
exhaust pipes of the [ __ ] those radial
engines every now and then they'd
backfire and pop
and it looked like a little flash and if
there were hundreds of planes in front
of you you just see these little [ __ ]
sparkles
going in front of you at night and it
was just that was the
it means you're looking at the back of a
bomber squadron
yeah we learn all kinds of new facts
castor oil in the engine doing that
yeah i was asking about uh what the hell
was on a breakfast uh
pizza santa said cheese and breakfast
sausage
and sauce so no eggs that's a bummer
okay i said i like a good loose
scrambled egg sandwich with mayo and
bacon on white bread toast that actually
sounds kind of good
yeah xander says basically a pizza with
light sauce and breakfast sausage
okay so it's not that different from
like a regular pizza
because it's still got sausage on it a
good a good um
breakfast sandwich that it is toast any
kind of nice toast
um scrambled eggs
with cheese bacon and guacamole
yeah american guacamole california style
guacamole
you don't have that just slices of damn
avocado
really good on it yeah i mean and
honestly i like a
a breakfast sandwich on a bagel yeah
it's good or a big-ass biscuit's good
too honestly
if we're going like because sometimes
when i when we go to mcdonald's i
usually want breakfast food
their sausage and egg biscuit is
their best thing yeah i think i always
get that
all right so you want to like yeah you
want to wrap it up that's good i think
we can go in a little more than an hour
yeah yeah you probably need a nap
or you know you probably got to make
pizza later
yeah and do some other [ __ ]
not too much other [ __ ] though because
i'm pretty tired too not as tired as i
thought it'd be oh i'll be all right
all right so we'll be back tomorrow uh
talking about a movie i don't know what
one yet it'll just be one we feel like
watching tonight
and talking about tomorrow so uh thanks
everybody for
coming by listening to us talk about
breakfast happy fourth of july
to all of you americans out there and uh
we will see you guys
tomorrow bye